hi I'm professor Charlie of the MU cool
like important institution and today I'm
gonna be answering the ultimate question
why had seen aged boys the way they are
we all know that on a molecular level
little boys are made of slugs snails and
puppy dogs tails but did you know that
teenage boys are made of pugs nails and
Marmite in fact teenage boys contain
more Marmite than any other demographic
one of the interesting facts about
teenage boys is that over the years
they've evolved their own language noted
language experts whose converse you of
grunt ISM you probably know it by its
mainstream name grunting here are a few
examples of the language little boys and
little girls all enjoy jokes about poo
poo but why well there's a little
cockroach that lives inside the brain of
all children that gets its sustenance
from the energy given off when a child
experiences a poopoo joke when a little
girl reaches 13 the cockroach falls out
of her nose and she grows up but in
little boy as the cockroach stays there
until they reach adulthood which is why
you'll find teenage boys and sometimes
even grown men finding the urge to laugh
at a simple joke about poo poo what are
the more recent discoveries regarding
teenage boys is the trend to wear your
trousers very very low around your waist
scientists have been wrestling with the
cause of this for years but some
philosophers believe that teenage bodies
do it because of something that they
refer to as cool personally I feel as
though the impracticality zuv wearing
your trousers so low around your waist
must undoubtably outweigh any kind of
cool factor but one thing we know for
certain is that it looks really really
stupid sit across the table from a
teenage boy and watch him eat what on
earth is he eating
teenage boys have very strange eating
habits but why well if you take a closer
look into the mouths of the teenage boy
you will notice that they don't actually
have a tongue nowadays prosthetics songs
are all the rage but as real as they may
look and feel they still can't taste so
if you ever see a teenage boy shoveling
a mixture
Pizza ice cream and dirt into his mouth
you'll know why he just can't taste it
hoo-ee what's that smell well it's the
distinctive width of a teenage boy who
hasn't washed for three years as we
previously mentioned a large proportion
of the teenage boy is made up of Marmite
and we all know what happens when you
put Marmite in water the only way that
teenage boys can clean themselves is by
rubbing butter into their skin canceling
out the surface Marmite which is what
gives teenage boys that distinctive
buttery smell and finally one of the
most frequently asked questions about
teenage boys is how do you get them to
like you and the answer is of course you
don't
don't try anything just be yourself the
best teenage boys are going to be the
ones that like you for who you are or by
them excessively banging pairs of jeans
tell them a bunch of poo poo jokes only
ever communicate using grunting rip your
tongue out and rub butter into your skin
and that's how you get teenage boys to
love you fat you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool